c'est sous les applaudissements que la
nouvelle rame de métro azur a fait sa
première apparition la station
henri-bourassa
ces nouvelles voitures remplaceront les
mr-63 qui roule depuis 1966 elles sont
mises à l'essai mais les passagers
devront d'abord se contenter de les
regarder passer sur wenning orange et
bleu en dehors des heures de pointe
si cependant avec près d'un an de retard
que bombardier alstom livre ses
premières voitures de métro plus d
espace 2 gens vont pouvoir le prendre et
puis on est en france livraison juin
recule très heureux quand même une année
ottawa l'important c'est ce qu'on peut
toujours trouver des bébêtes mesdames
aujourd'hui jetant mode on peut savoir
des résultats alors soyons contents
qu'il y avait un problème de logiciel
sur le pré pour rien y faire il s'agit
d'une première rame d'une commande de
468 voitures un contrat de deux
milliards 400 millions de dollars
un métro ultra moderne est aussi moins
chaud parce que la chaleur du freinage
sera récupérée par les voitures est
transformée en énergie électrique
dsr déjà été effectuées la nuit mais là
c'est la première fois qu'il soit on
fait deux jours c'est le faire rouler le
plus possible ses seuls intérêts
justement de rouler de jour
contrairement à la nuit où on est très
très limité là on veut le faire rouler
pour vraiment voir au niveau de sa
fiabilité des problématiques on peut
rencontrer audrey plus confortable aussi
plus spacieux qui pourrait accueillir 8
% plus de passagers la mise en service
maintenant de ce train avec passagers
devrait se faire fin décembre début
janvier
si tout va bien issigeac bissonnet radio
canada montréal